and is directly antithetical to
everything Western values stand for and
it is an inferior culture in all ways
now the funny thing is this he talks
about being an inferior culture this is
his bedroom bro look this is his bedroom
bro you think that's bad check this out
he was caught on YouTube check this out
bro
yeah Islam net is establishing a Masid
and a community center if you donate to
build this Masid Allah will in build a
house for you in Jen with of gold and
silver every person who prays in this
Masid every child that memorizes the
Quran you will in share in that reward
donate now guys and do not
[Music]
delay brothers and sisters and dear
friends so I saw this video and I found
it so hilarious because there was so
much irony in it okay we're going to get
straight into it apparently some
YouTuber in America called asman asman
gold or something for that matter yeah
so here's a video and he's having his
take on the whole Palestinian uh Israeli
the genocide that's happening and this
is what he had to say if you want to
consider a genocide as a systematic
killing of a group of people they have
genocide built into Sharia law right now
so no I'm not going to cry a [__]
River when people who have genocide
that's baked into their laws are getting
genocided I don't give a [__] they're
terrible people it's not even a question
it's crazy that people don't see see it
that
way they'd be doing the same
thing and how much did they kill as many
as they
can they're not able to kill as many
people as Israel because they don't have
as many bombs and as many weapons but if
they did they'd be doing the same thing
that's it just takes enough that's right
these people are not your allies they
are not the same as us they come from
inferior culture that is horrible it
kills people for their identity and is
directly antithetical to everything
Western value stand for and it is an
inferior culture in all
ways it is that simple no I don't feel
bad for them I don't feel sorry for them
I don't care I don't support them okay
now just want to show you some stuff
here it's very very you know what's
funny about it he said they they're an
inferior culture okay so this is what he
said the um a couple of weeks ago he
goes weird as F to see so many people
coming out with the statements about the
Israeli Palestine conflict as if they
need to comment on it can we please stop
this weird culture around expecting
people with no relevant background or
education to talk about to world events
and politics he's a flipping gamer okay
now the funny thing is this he talks
about being an inferior culture this is
his bedroom bro look this is his
[Laughter]
bedroom bro this is his bedroom do you
want to see something more funny you
want to see something more funny he's
talking about being inferior yeah bro
that looks like a trash can Trash Can
looks M bro you think that's bad check
this out he was caught on YouTube check
this out bro
yeah there's a ro flying at me give me a
minute look watch look watch
this watch this look there's a cockroach
on
him bro what are you doing bro get out
of my bro his house is so dirty there's
cockroaches flying on him did you just
see that this cockroaches flying on him
bro yeah now I found that so flipping
ironic bro look at this this is
disgusting this is a filthy way of
living bro it looks like there's feces
on the floor and he's talking about
inferior we've been inferior culture
okay that was the iron like it was crazy
bro Subhan Allah the first thing I want
to mention is he's like he's making
these bold claims about thear for a
genocide is there anywhere in our
Islamic Traditions Quran statement of
the scholars you name it anywhere about
committing genocide that's to the
contrary I think uh you know best uh
First Samuels what what do it say there
yeah well by if he's a Christian 1 Sam
15:3 no but Jews will follow that
because it's the Old Testament right
exactly so the funny thing is what does
it say in that verse again it says kill
go to the amikit and kill men women
children babies and donkeys and it's
it's relevant because nanyu mentioned
theit what did to you yes and this is
mentioned many times you know and there
is no equivalent verse in the Quran
anywhere and the funny thing is he's
saying that if they had the power they
would have done it nowhere in our
literature that's so funny bro that they
accuse us of something that's why
projection every accusation is a
confession so nowhere in the Sharia and
I challenge you yes I I me or hijab
every dirty hij he doesn't I'll
challenge you to any discussion or
debate on this topic that anywhere in
the Quran or the Sunnah it teaches us to
be genocidal nowhere in Islam challenge
him to a FIFA match no no I can do Call
of Duty I'll smash him call of duty all
day every day that's the only thing he
can good yeah yeah we we yes exactly so
the thing is number one nowhere in the
Sharia you don't know nothing about the
Sharia you're just absolute ignoramus
you look at your bedroom but what a
disgusting place to live okay I would
have recommend another disgusting place
exactly like a junkie okay like a junkie
I would have I would have recommend that
other scumbag book uh what um Jordan Pon
your room clean your clean your room
yeah okay now talking about inferior
inferior culture yeah he's talking about
Islam let me tell you something culture
ask question when was the last time you
washed your
ass wash his face more when was the last
time you washed your backside he hasn't
even cleaned his room listen in Islam we
know the basic etiquette of washing your
backside you don't even wash your
backside bro okay look at your bedroom
you live in absolute filth and you want
to come here and he made an apology by
the way his apology was very CL I think
sponsors canel him let me he got some
sponsors yeah he's got some sponsors
yeah let me see if it goes he needs to
sponsor for Breeze exactly no no he
needs a problem forget Hoover company
company yeah no bleach bleach bleach
need to sponsor his videos looking back
on it I was way too much of an [__]
about the Palestine thing my bad of
course no one deserves to have their
life destroyed even if they do things
even if they do things or have views I
find regressive you guys deserve more
than me saying stupid no man we don't
buy apology man you clown your sponsors
probably um will canceling you is this
guy on
Twitch he's got like two million on
YouTube wherever wherever he is must
report it must report this flipping
scumbag the only reason it's apologizing
is because his probably sponsors are
canceling on him I mean any last words
bro I mean we
don't he's nothing he's a nobody he's a
nobody exactly that's it brother and
sisters
inshah check our next video in we're
reacting to the scum bag Nas daily the
one who his wife left him without giving
him anything that's the next video
insh The Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tala tells us that our books will be
given and every little atam weight of
Good Deed we've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a mid I never
had the money to build a Masid Allah you
helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you've
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
Rewards
[Music]